En este video resolveremos un par de ecuaciones
a manera de calentamiento, las cuales para
resolverlas requieren más pasos de los que
hecho en videos previos.
Posteriormente resolveremos un problema de
aplicación donde pondremos a prueba nuestras
habilidades para resolver ecuaciones.
Aquí tenemos, 7 por "w" más 20 menos "w"
es igual a 5, veamos cómo resolverla y como
en todas las ecuaciones, hay muchas maneras
de resolverlas, yo haré la que me parece más natural.
Para empezar, voy a distribuir los números,
así distribuyendo el 7 obtendré "7w"
a lo cuál le podré restar "w" y así tener las
"w" juntas de alguna manera.
Entonces, aplicando la propiedad distributiva
7 por "w" más 20, es igual a 7 por "w" más
7 por 20, más 140, estamos aplicando la propiedad
distributiva y a eso le restamos "w", "-w"
lo cual es igual a 5.
Únicamente reescribí esto, distribuí el 7.
Y ahora ya podemos juntar las "w", aquí
tenemos "7w"menos "w",
eso es "7w" menos "w" es "6w", acuérdate, si tienes 7 de algo y le restas 1 de algo te da 6 de ese algo,
"6w" más 140 y eso es igual a 5.
Ahora, quiero deshacerme de este 140 del lado
izquierdo para dejar "6w" y así dividiendo
entre 6 obtendría la solución de la ecuación.
Para deshacerme de este 140, voy a restar
140 a ambos lados de la ecuación.
Entonces restamos 140 del lado izquierdo,
aquí hay que ponerle el signo "más", 140
del lado derecho, si un algo es igual a otro
algo, un algo -140 va a ser igual al otro
algo -140, en una ecuación lo que hagas de
un lado, lo tienes que hacer del otro lado.
El objetivo de este paso fue cancelar estos
140 y nos queda, del lado izquierdo "6w" y del lado derecho 5 menos 140 y eso es igual a -135.
Ahora dividimos ambos lados entre 6, que es lo mismo que multiplicar por 1/6 ambos lados
y del lado izquierdo ¿qué nos queda?
6 entre 6 es 1, nos queda "w" y del lado derecho
nos queda -135/6.
Y esto ya no se puede simplificar más, veamos
esto no es divisible entre 2 y tampoco es
divisible entre 3, así es que parece ser
que ya hemos resuelto la ecuación.
Y esta solución es algo que tú podrías
comprobar, de hecho, vamos a comprobarla.
Pues este número me parece un poco extraño,
entonces sustituyendo en la ecuación original,
es 7 por "w" que es -135/6 y eso más 20,
pero voy a poner el 20 como 120/6,
20 es lo mismo que 120/6 y a eso le
vamos a restar "w" que es menos...
-135/6 y aquí tenemos menos por menos esto
es más, así es que esto es más 135/6
y ahora tenemos 7 por -135/6 más 120/6 y esto
es igual a -15/6, 7 por -15/6 más 135/6.
Veamos qué obtenemos.
Aquí tenemos 7 por -15/6...
7 por -15/6, vamos a hacerlo por acá, 7 por
-15 es 7 por 10 = 70, 7 por 5 = 35,
esto sería -105/6, eso corresponde a esta cantidad de
aquí y a eso le sumamos 135/6, que es este
término que tenemos aquí.
-105/6 más 135/6 es igual a 30/6,
que es igual a 5, 5 era lo que necesitábamos que
fuera, así es que estamos bien, ésta es
la solución, me pareció un número un poco
raro pero no, hicimos las cosas adecuadamente,
resolvamos ahora esta ecuación.
Distribuyamos primeramente el 9, como hemos
dicho hay varias maneras de hacer esto, posteriormente
veremos otra manera, por lo pronto distribuyamos
el 9 para no tener que hacer operaciones con
fracciones.
Entonces distribuyendo el 9, ¿qué obtenemos?
"9x" menos 18 es igual a "3x" más 3.
Ahora, vamos a agrupar las "x" del lado izquierdo,
para eso necesitamos restar "3x" del lado derecho,
"-3x" del lado derecho y "-3x" del
lado izquierdo, recuerda que hay que hacer
lo mismo del lado derecho que del lado izquierdo.
Entonces restamos "3x" a ambos lados,
¿qué nos resulta?
Del lado izquierdo tenemos "-3x" más "9x"
es igual a "6x" menos 18, "6x" menos 18, del
lado derecho "3x" y "-3x" se cancela
y nos queda simplemente 3.
Ahora, hay varias maneras de hacer esto pero
vamos a seguir el método tradicional.
Esto es, vamos a sumar 18 a ambos lados,
sumamos 18 del lado izquierdo y
sumamos 18 del lado derecho,
¿qué obtenemos del lado izquierdo? 18 con
menos 18 se cancelan, nos queda solo "6x"
esos términos se cancelaron y del lado derecho
nos queda 3 más 18 es igual a 21,
dividimos entre 6 ambos lados, 6 entre 6 es 1, nos queda "x" del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho
es 21/6, simplificamos 21/6 sacando tercera
arriba y tercera abajo, nos va a dar 7/2.
Y ya hemos acabado, bien, dije que había
varias maneras de hacer esto, voy a resolver
la ecuación de otra manera aquí, en naranja.
Tenemos "9x" menos 2 esto es igual a 3 por "x" más 3.
Bueno, aquí lo que se me ocurre es dividir entre 3 ambos lados de la ecuación,
vamos a dividir entre 3 del lado izquierdo y del lado derecho hay que dividir entre 3, ambos sumandos.
Dividimos entre 3 del lado izquierdo, 9 entre
3 me queda 3 que multiplica a "x" menos 2
y esto es igual, "3x" entre 3 es igual a "x" más 1.
Ya podemos distribuir el 3 del lado izquierdo, lo cual nos va a quedar, "3x" menos 6 es igual a "x" más 1.
Vamos a agrupar las "x" del lado izquierdo,
vamos a restar "x" a ambos lados, del lado
izquierdo es "2x" menos 6, del lado derecho
sería simplemente 1, restamos esta "x", restamos
esta "x" para eliminarla.
Ahora, sumando 6 a ambos lados nos queda del lado izquierdo, "2x" y del lado derecho queda, 1 más 6 = 7,
dividiendo entre 2 obtenemos "x" es igual a 7/2.
Fui algo rápido en estos pasos, pero quería
mostrarte que mientras los pasos que sigas
sean matemáticamente válidos, vas a obtener
siempre, exactamente la misma respuesta.
Y puedes verificar esta respuesta en la ecuación
original si así lo deseas.
Y ahora tenemos un problema de aplicación,
veamos si podemos resolverlo.
Lidia heredó cierta cantidad de dinero, la
cual dividió en cinco partes iguales.
Digamos que "m" es la cantidad de dinero que
tiene, el cual dividió en 5 partes iguales,
digamos que "m" es entonces el dinero de Lidia...
dinero de Lidia, el cual heredó...
heredado, dinero de Lidia heredado...
el cual dividió en 5 partes iguales.
Ella invirtió tres partes del dinero en una
cuenta bancaria de interés alto,
¿así que cuánto invirtió en la cuenta con un alto
interés bancario?
Entonces, con un alto interés...
interés bancario, ¿cuánto invirtió?
Lidia lo dividió en 5 partes iguales y de
esas 5 partes iguales, 3 las invirtió a un
alto interés bancario, entonces su cantidad
de dinero "m" la dividió en 5 partes iguales
y de esas, 3 las invirtió en la cuenta bancaria,
también podríamos decir que 3/5 de su dinero,
podemos decir entonces que 3/5 de su dinero
lo invirtió en una cuenta con un alto interés
bancario con la cual aumentaba 10% de su valor, eso fue lo que invirtió en la cuenta de alto interés bancario.
Ella invirtió el resto de la herencia más 500 dólares en el mercado de valores,
¿y cuánto fue esto?
Tenemos ahora que en el mercado de valores
ahí invirtió el resto de la herencia,
así es que si invirtió 3/5 partes en la cuenta
bancaria, ¿cuánto le queda?
Le quedan 2/5 partes del dinero, lo cual va
a invertir en el mercado de valores,
¿de acuerdo? Si sumas 3/5 y 2/5, tienes todo el dinero
que ella heredó, pero no invirtió únicamente
eso, invirtió el resto de su dinero 2/5 partes de "m",
más 500 dólares...
más 500 dólares, en el mercado de valores,
pero perdió 20%.
Así que esto fue lo que invirtió y terminó con...
vamos a poner aquí esto es lo invertido y terminó con...
vamos a ponerlo por acá... terminó con...
Así que en la cuenta bancaria...
en la cuenta bancaria aumentó 10% su valor,
así es que empezó con 3/5 partes de su dinero...
3/5 partes de su dinero y le agregó 10% de su valor,
vamos a ponerlo así, 0.10 que es el 10% de lo que invirtió, 0.10 por 3/5 de "m".
Esto es con lo que termina. la cantidad original,
más un 10% que se le agregó, el 10% que
creció la inversión.
Ahora, en el mercado de valores empezó con
esta cantidad, con 2/5 de "m" más 500 y perdió
20% de esa cantidad, es decir menos .2 el 20% de la cantidad que invirtió, de 2/5 de "m" más 500,
eso es lo que pierde, el 20% de la cantidad que invirtió.
Y nos dicen, si las dos cuentas terminaron
con exactamente la misma cantidad de dinero,
¿cuánto heredó ella?
Así que ésta y ésta terminan siendo iguales,
una ecuación para "m" por resolver.
Hagamos eso. Tenemos 3/5 de
"m" más .10 por 3/5, .10 lo puedo escribir como 1
sobre 10, así es que multiplicando 1 sobre 10 por 3/5 de "m" tenemos 3 sobre 50 "m",
lo único que hice fue multiplicar 1/10 por 3/5, nos da 3 sobre 50 y esto va
a ser igual a 2/5...
no, voy a usar el mismo color,
déjame usar el mismo color...
Esto va a ser igual a 2...
No, sigue saliendo el mismo color salmón...
A ver, ahora sí, el mismo color.
Esto va a ser igual a 2/5 de "m" más 500
menos .2 por 2/5, .2 es igual a 1/5,
hagámoslo por aquí, .2 es igual a 20 sobre 100 y eso
es igual a 1/5, sustituimos este .2 por 1/5.
Entonces, aquí nos queda, -1/5 que
multiplica a 2/5 más...
perdón, 2/5 de "m", 1/5 que multiplica a
2/5 de "m" más 500, este es un problema peliagudo
pero haciéndolo poco a poco veremos
que no es tan difícil.
Para empezar tenemos que sumar 3/5 de algo
más 3/50 de algo, 3/5 es lo mismo que 30/50,
estoy multiplicando por 10 el numerador y
por 10 el denominador y ahora sumamos 30/50
más 3/50, eso nos va a dar 33/50 de "m" y
eso es igual a...
vamos a simplificar el lado derecho, sería
2/5 de "m" más 500 y vamos a distribuir este
-1/5, -1/5 por 2/5 es, -2/25 de "m" y -1/5
por 500 es -100, simplifiquemos esto aun más,
el lado izquierdo permanece, "33/50m" y eso
es igual a, los términos en "m" son,
2/5 de "m" y -2/25 de "m", lo vamos a poner como
2/5 - 2/25 y todo eso multiplicado por "m",
simplemente he factorizado las "m" aquí y acá,
ya usamos esos términos y luego tenemos
500 menos 100, eso es más 400.
Ahora veamos, aquí tenemos 2/5,
si multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por 5 nos resulta 10/25.
Y la ecuación resulta ahora, "33/50m" es
igual a 10/25 menos 2/25 es igual a "8/25m"
más 400, nos estamos acercando.
Pasemos ahora a las "m" del lado izquierdo
de la ecuación, restamos "-8/25m" del lado derecho y también restamos "-8/25m" del lado izquierdo,
del lado derecho "8/25m" menos "8/25m" se cancelan y nos queda simplemente 400,
del lado izquierdo tenemos "-8/25m" más
"33/50m", esto lo podemos escribir como 33/50
y -8/25 lo podemos escribir como -16/50, multipliqué
por 2 el numerador y el denominador y obtuve
16/50 y eso multiplicado por "m" va a ser igual a 400.
Ya casi llegamos, 33/50 menos 16/50, 33 menos
16 es 17, así es que este término es igual
a "17/50m" y esto es igual a 400.
Vamos a despejar "m", multiplicamos por el
recíproco de 17/50 que es 50/17, lo hacemos
por ambos lados para mantener la ecuación,
estos términos se cancelan y nos queda tan
solo "m" es igual a 400 por 50 entre 17.
Saquemos la calculador, esto va a ser igual a 400 por 50 entre 17, esto nos va a dar igual a 1176.47.
"m" es igual entonces a 1176.47 dólares.
Eso fue lo que recibió Lidia de herencia,
espero que te hayas divertido con este video.